Let's pray together. Day 20, Romans chapter 12,
making a full surrender.
Lord, I thank you for the beautiful metaphor in your
word today
that calls us to yield ourselves.
Oh God, we are so good at standing up for ourselves.
We are so good at resisting every other
call. We're so programmed to believe that our
freedom is dependent on our own grasping of our
strength and our right to determine ourselves.
But oh God, you call us to a different path.
You call us not to grasping for our own way
and our own will, but yielding our own way and our own
will.
And so, Lord, thank you. Thank you for teaching us that it's necessary
for us to present our bodies. Thank you, Lord, for calling
to us and reminding us of the importance of
yielding it as Christians, holy and acceptable to God.
So Lord, we do that right now. Here's our hands, Lord. Here's my hands.
Take my hands and what I click and what I type and what I touch
and what I do and how I work. Lord, here's my
mind and my brain and what I think about and
what I mull over and meditate on. Here's my mouth and what I take
in and what I say and what I put out. Lord, here's my
feet and where I go and where I stop.
And Lord, here's every part of me, my eyes and what
I look at and the way I see people. Lord,
here's my ears and what I listen to and what
I hear. Lord, we yield ourselves
wholeheartedly, body, soul, and spirit,
everything given over to you. Not so
that we will stop sinning, but because we've been made
holy. Not because we're lost and broken, but because we've been
made holy by the blood of Christ. We yield all these things because of
your great mercy, because it just makes sense.
It's the rational, reasonable, normal thing to do.
So we surrender to you in Christ's name.
You're probably hearing some noise in the background.
As I told you a couple of days ago, I'm praying over each of you
today as we seek the Lord together. I'm driving.
I'm on my way to the hospital, and I'm just leaving the hospital from visiting
someone. So thank you for putting up with the noises in the
background. Let's continue seeking the Lord together now as we pray.